We should bear in mind
that we don't have a capitalist system
that no capitalist system has ever survived.
It would self destruct in 5 minutes.
Uh, so what we have is kind of state capitalist system,
with the state playing a substantial role
in American history,
a very substantial world in economic development,
in production and the research and development.
So is there an alternative to this? Of course.
For example,
the alternative that was
taken for granted by 19th century workers
before it was sort of beaten out of people's heads
by massive propaganda,
namely that
those who work in the Mills should own them
and run them.
Yeah, that's very natural.
As I say, we've come close to that a number of times.
Terrifying to private owners.
They also held that wage labor
is basically no different from chattel slavery,
except that it's temporary.
And that was such a popular idea that it was a.
It was a position of the Republican Party,
Abraham Lincoln espouse.
And it makes sense,
I mean, that there's nothing holy about which labor
you are renting yourself,
which is not very different from being a slave,
except that maybe it lands on time.
Those aren't laws of nature,
those are political decisions.
Social, economic
and political decisions that can be made differently.
If they're made differently enough,
we'll be moving towards a, uh,
you know, kind of anarchist type society.